das heißt sie werden dafür dass es ein
zweites Parteiausschlussverfahren gibt
gegen Sahra Wagenknecht
ich glaube nicht dass man das Problem
mit einem Parteiausschluss löst und das
ist zwar bei uns also das
muss glaube ich durch einen klare
Beschlüsse wo steht die Partei wo steht
die Fraktion entschieden werden
echtes Problem ich würde gerne was
aussprechen was Frau Kipping glaube ich
nicht aussprechen darf Frau Wagenknecht
erpresst die Linke
die Linke hat eine Fraktion im Bundestag
und Frau Wagenknecht hat sechs harte
Anhänger darin mit ihr zusammen sind das
sieben wenn die nicht mehr in der
Fraktion mitmachen ist der
Fraktionsstatus weg weil wenn man unter
eine gewisse Anzahl fällt hat man den
nicht mehr dann ist man nur noch eine
Gruppe im Bundestag hat man weniger
Rechte parlamentarisch weniger
Mitarbeiter und so weiter